so I'm gonna be talking about the web
data blind spots so when I say this term
web data blind spot a lot of you may be
thinking well web data is obviously
instantly accessible already right what
blind spot is there really for me to
talk about so I'm going to this is the
most useless light in the deck I'm going
to illustrate this point by playing a
game with you all so can anyone in here
ask a trivia question that someone else
in there anyone else knew him cannot
answer so you're probably thinking of
some things you probably could but
you're a little too shy to raise your
hand but what if I now allowed
smartphones in the game right now you're
thinking okay that question that I had
in my mind maybe not so unanswerable now
right so I think this is a really
powerful concept the idea that the web
is basically an extension of our own
mind now so thanks to consumers search
applications we basically know
everything that we'd want to know as a
person there's just a little bit of lag
introducing the equation which I perfect
claim happy to live with now the strange
thing is is that if I were to ask
similar questions to your business I
would argue that your business does not
have the same capability so businesses
are actually quite disconnected from the
web because they have different kinds of
questions that they want to ask so if
you play the same game again and I even
gave you more time let's say an hour you
know could your business ask questions
like or could it answer questions like
which states are underserved by hotels
or what pricing strategies do luxury
shoe brands use or where is
crowdsourcing rentals most successful so
these are all questions that have data
out there on the web right so if we go
back to the
first question which states are
underserved by hotel so we can look at
things like locations of hotels that
data's on the web we can look at reviews
of hotels that data is on the web the
problem is that that data is scattered
across dozens or hundreds of websites
and maybe thousands of websites you
consider niche properties and all that
data is in a sense formatted in a
different format across each of these
properties right so obviously the HTML
on one website is different from the
Asian on the other website so this if we
start thinking of each website as its
own data store these data stores now
have completely different formats
they're not interoperable and things
like that so that creates a huge problem
but obviously someone the hospitality an
issue would love to answer this question
because this is a market opportunity
that is hidden in the data somewhere
right same thing here product data is
even worse there's you know potentially
hundreds of thousands of websites where
this information exists we all go to
those websites every day but it's really
difficult for us for a business to
access all information at once they
don't want to know the price of one shoe
they want to know the price of every
shoe right and they want to segment that
by their competitors they want to see
how that price changes over time things
like that so and of course this is a
interesting question that starting to
pop up now as well so well we've done a
date affinity is actually make all that
sort of force that data to be
interoperable basically going over the
entire web and pulling all that content
into a single formats that standardized
across every source and then making that
data searchable so in a sense kind of
like a b2b version of Google so what I'm
going to do is walk through some
examples of data that does answer these
questions and I'm going to show you a
couple visualizations that we've done
with some folks and some other folks
that kind of highlight what answers can
be pulled out of that data
um so let me so I put links in here but
bit ly doesn't like making rest api
calls for some reason so no copy this
guy and so this is 0 the json view thing
okay great of course so Jason V is not
on this thing I was hoping it was that's
okay so this is really hard to read of
course now but what this is is basically
i put in a query you can kind of see it
up here coroner api it says give me a
bunch of reviews in json formats that
have the category hotel in the US and
they have reviews and they've been
updated back in the last month or so and
so you can see a bunch of bunch of
reviews in here if you look closely a
little hard to see though but the idea
here is that this data has been like i
said source for multiple websites and
now it's in one single feed so then i
can now actually start working with that
data so let me go back here and click on
the sky so we did an analysis of about
400,000 hotel reviews across 50 states
found some surprising stuff so we
cleared like little d3 realization
around this happy to report that texas
where we live is doing pretty well
surprisingly washington DC has terrible
hotel reviews like 2.7 that's like
atrocious right like below 3 is really
bad hawaii does really well oklahoma and
idaho do really well that's weird sorry
if anyone's in those states just not
what I was expecting
then we took we also sort of correlated
this with sort of other sources of
public data is so like population data
you can see states like Nevada have a
you know our huge outliers because those
are obviously that's obviously a
destination state all right and then
other states do quite poorly for the
reviews they produced per population we
also do the same thing with tourism
budget so we collect a little bit of
tourism budget data this was a little
harder to collect on a year-by-year
basis so we kind of fudged a little bit
but you can see interesting things here
like California and Nevada do really
well as far as producing reviews based
on the budget they spend but Hawaii does
surprisingly poorly so I'm not sure how
directly related these things are but
it's an interesting relationship to look
at and the idea here again is that this
the source of this information is out
there on the web but it was very
difficult to pull into before we had
this data feed coming in so kind of like
how we've talked about with other topics
here during them during the summit once
you actually have data become available
all this and all these things become
really easy and so and we're not an
analytics company we just provide data
and so we're just like okay what's a
simple thing we can answer and boom
there it was so that's the hotel example
so then we pull up a shoe pricing data
so I'll quickly show you the
indecipherable shoe data without the
plug-in oh I don't have my token
nevermind strange
okay well okay I'll show you that but I
can show you interesting visualization
on shoe data okay so here what we did is
we pulled out I think it was about
25,000 different shoes I think they're
probably multiple prices per shoe and we
took the average of every shoe brand and
we also manually divided them between
luxury and nonlinear shoes so what you
can see there there's a dashed line that
runs down the side that's the average
price of non-luxury shoes and then each
of these are luxury shoe brands so
actually my wife was the main consultant
on who determined luxury versus
non-luxury so we've got like tory burch
at the top and it's a bottom we've got
brunello cucinelli is anyway now here's
the interesting thing again we're not in
an analytics company but we quickly saw
some patterns in this data again because
it's now available so we actually saw
there's kind of like a three by three
pricing matrix or pricing strategy
matrix that all these guys used one is
sort of a clustering around average
prices and another is a clustering
around distribution of prices so the
average price you'll kind of see there's
a small group at the top that clusters
around like a $300 range there's a large
group that clusters between like 600 to
800 and there's a group that clusters
around a thousand and up so that's one
dimension and then what we found was
there was essentially three pricing
distribution there's an other category
but there's very few of those so there's
guys who have sort of a normal
distribution all right so Tory Burch
here and being in a room full of folks
that are very adept at math these are
not pure normal distributions but
approximately ones let's see who else
Barney's of New York a little more of a
ski 21 but then we have something called
we call our team
anchor which we kind of defined as a
clustering of shoes that lies like I
think two or more price buckets away
from the mean so that's like a price
book is like a hundred dollar range
basically so let's pull up one of those
guys Prada oops fresh this let's try
again tory burch there we go okay so
you've got their main cluster around
here but then you see they've got a
bunch of shoes out here as well so like
six years in the a hand dollar range
when they're mean shoe is seven hundred
dollars I think Jimmy Choo does this as
well right and then we've got another
group that does a double-dip stretches
basically two overlapping normal
distributions that are kind of separated
sleep love one of those guys Giorgio
Armani now this guy has oh why is it
doing that that's weird try again no
that's there we go so givenchy has a
bunch of shoes in this sort of eight
hundred dollar range yes and then a
bunch of shoes in this fitting Honor
arranged so and they all kind of use
this through by three pricing strategies
so again not being the shoe business not
even really being in the analytics
business we pulled out this data really
quickly because it's now available and
this is a cross I think dozens of retail
websites so that was really cool so
unfortunately i don't have an example
for the crowd cheering data yet because
we just launched that kind of data but
i'm sure we all sorts interesting
opportunities there with because that'll
include crouching data like rentals and
also property as well so we're
interested to see what kind of analysis
can be pulled out of that
so the idea that I'd like to sort of
expound upon is that we've talked a lot
about how interesting analysis becomes
available once the data becomes
accessible and a lot of folks here
talked about well the hardest part is
just getting the data in the first place
or the problem we run into the most is
the date is just unavailable and this
problem is very much true when it comes
to companies trying to access
information on the web just hasn't
really been thought about that much
because things like you know google has
made it so easy to get that information
as a person but a business wants to do
that at scale and now that it's becoming
accessible we're really interested to
see what kind of applications get built
on top of our date and anyone else who
is providing this so just the idea that
what happens when your business knows
everything the web knows that's a huge
influx information in potential insights
we think a lot of interesting
applications analysis will be done once
it becomes available so that's the
general as you want to leave you with
and hopefully you guys can think of some
things with that thanks